après les débats musclés l'assemblée
nationale les sénateurs s'empare du
projet de loi de gestion de la sortie de
crise sanitaire première lecture depuis
cet après midi ici au palais du
luxembourg dans un hémicycle dominé par
des sénateurs de droite pour ce texte
déjà adopté ce lundi à l'assemblée
nationale c'est l'article 1 qui porte
notamment sur le pass sanitaire qui a
été à l'origine de certaines et dix
cornes les députés modem l'ont d'abord
rejeté
dénonçant un texte trop floue après
négociation avec l'exécutif la date de
sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire a
été ramené au 30 septembre contre le 31
octobre prévu initialement
il seconde délibération autorisé par le
règlement a finalement permis l'adoption
de l'article litigieux
la majorité sénatoriale de droite et du
centre veut aller encore plus loin
notamment concernant le pass sanitaire
s'ils sont d'accord avec le principe
les sénateurs veulent mieux que
circonscrire ce pass sanitaire philippe
baqué le rapporteur l air propose de
faire la différence entre les événements
extérieurs et les événements intérieurs
en précisant clairement que le pass and
i ter ne peut être mise en oeuvre que
pour les lieux où événements impliquant
des grands rassemblements autrement dit
plus de 1000 personnes
les sénateurs veulent un régime qui
limite la restriction pour le
gouvernement et mieux défendre les
libertés individuelles et la protection
des données afin d'éviter certaines
dérives